I have to ask you first of all I've
talked to you before you've got facial
hair now you got some scruff going here
yes this way I haven't cut it since the
last time I sorry this is a solid year's
worth of growth solid year Wow
incredible
why no cuz so many other people in the
cast the other male members have scruff
all the time because they're fighting
zombies they're obviously not shaving
your character never any scruff what's
what's going on have you ever tried to
go for it yeah actually last season I
came in with something close to this and
I walked in and Lauren was there I was
like hey what do you think of this and
lauren cohan who plays maggie she was
like because she has to kiss this yes
and then uh Donna przemek our makeup
head and she came up to me and was much
more blunt and she said you look like an
a-hole
a French angle okay we'll shave it so
you got rid of it all right now you live
what seven months out of the year here
in Atlanta yes okay you got to tell me
I've only got a little bit of time left
here I've got about another two days
what should I not miss while I'm in town
you should go to the Clermont lounge
Steve and ice the crowd seems to think
you've made the correct pick even the
Pope is going for it what wait tell us
of tell it because a lot of people
watching different parts of the country
what's the Clermont launch what are we
talking about it's it's actually thing
this is a high-class mall or yes it's a
great place it has awesome music really
fun
daivi place but there's a slight caveat
there's also it's an open stripping area
for stripping area sounds like strippers
wandering from the woods or there's some
kind of mining going up free-for-all
strip yeah but it's it's mostly older
older beautiful ladies older ladies
disrobe and and and and you have
witnessed this yes what are you like cuz
you seem like a you seem like I can
relate to you because I would be in that
situation I'd be a little nervous maybe
self-conscious you seem like you how
would you react in that situation yeah
I'm not good I haven't been to too many
strip clubs but of the ones that I go to
I'm really awkward and I'm like I'm that
guy that's like probably every stripper
hates where it's like this is this is
cool where are you from like you smell
so good what was your major like you
want to want to be so nice because you
know it's crazy but then like at the
Clermont lounge like it's even more
because you're like wow I didn't think
you could do that
laws went so much further than I thought
it would but the key is they have that
one of the one of the ladies she's so
great so sweet she does this amazing
thing where I don't know the entire
crowd is like oh yeah I've got a drawing
I got what happened was after it was
done and I was done being awkward she
was like do you want me to do my special
thing and I was like sure of course sort
of that as always yes yes yeah so she
gets a rap sheet what's up and she just
does this for like a couple minutes just
like shaking beer cans like finding an
empty one then she locates an empty one
turns around puts it in her butt cheeks
and then crushes it
then she signs it forget she signs it
just to make sure that funny you got me
when she signs it
yes I was looking and II like we go now
well I do like people when they recycle
[Laughter]
[Applause]